DAN: IT'S BEEN A LONG WEEK FOR
FLORIDANS AS FLORIDA RECOVERS
FROM THE DEVASTATION LEFT BEHIND
HURRICANE IAN.
HE HAS HAD SOME VICIOUS ATTACKS
FROM THE MEDIA, ESPECIALLY
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT'S VISIT.
HOW IS IT GOING AND HOW CAN
PEOPLE HELP?
>> THE BEST WAY TO HELP IS GO
TOP Floridadisasterfund.org.
THAT MONEY WILL GO TO VOLUNTEER
FLORIDA THERE IS NO CHARGE FROM
MASTERCARD OR VISA FOR THE
CHARGES.
WE HAVE HAD A LOST PEOPLE HELP
US.
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE BEST WAY.
WE HAD A MASSIVE RESPONSE
STAGED.
WE HAVE 24,000 LINEMEN STAGED,
COAST GUARD STAGED AND RESCUE
STAGED.
WE HAVE 99 PLUS PERCENT OF POWER
IS ON, AND MOST FLORIDIANS HAD
RELATIVELY MODEST INTERRUPTIONS.
WE ARE WORK ON GETTING PEOPLE
BACK ON THEIR FEES WHO WERE
DISPLACED.
THERE ARE UNFORTUNATELY PEOPLE
WHOSE HOMES WERE DESTROYED OR
SEVERELY DAMAGED.
BUT IT HAS BEEN A ROBUST EFFORT
AND I THINK THE PEOPLE OF
FLORIDA APPRECIATE EVERYBODY WHO
HAS BEEN INVOLVED WITH THIS,
ESPECIALLY THE FIRST RESPONDERS.
DAN: I KNOW THE AREA WELL.
WHEN I RAN FOR CONGRESS I
KNOCKED ON A LOT OF DOORS.
THE PINE ISLAND BRIDGE.
YOU WOUND UP GETTING A BRIDGE UP
RATHER QUICKLY IN JUST A FEW
DAYS.
HOW DID YOU GUYS GET THAT UP AND
RUNNING SO FAST IN JUST A COUPLE
DAYS.
AND WHAT ABOUT SANIBEL, ANY
TIMELINE ON THAT?
>> PINE ISLAND BRIDGE, THE ROAD
TO THE BRIDGE GOT SNOK KNOCKED
OUT.
THEY WERE ADVISED TO DEPART FROM
THE ISLAND BECAUSE THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE ACCESSIBILITY.
BUT THAT NOT WHAT THEY WANTED TO
DO.
THEY WANT TO STAY IN THEIR
HOMES.
THEY SAID CAN THE STATE HELP
WITH THE ROAD AND THE BRIDGE.
I SAID YES WE'LL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
WITHIN THREE DAYS WERE ABLE TO
REOPEN THE BRIDGE.
WE -- WE HAVE PUBLIX SENDING
THEIR TRUCKS.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THEY ARE ABLE
TO GET BACK ON THEIR FEET.
SANIBEL WE ALSO SAID WE WOULD
TAKE CARE OF THAT.
THAT CAUSEWAY SEVERED IN THREE
DIFFERENT PLACES.
SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
DEPTH.
WE BELIEVE WE'LL HAVE IT DONE
THIS WEEK.
IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND NATIONAL GUARD.
WE ARE BRINGING UTILITY WORKERS
TO GET ON THAT ISLAND AND START
MAKING SENSE OF THE ELECTRIC
SITUATION.
WHEN I TOURED THAT IN PERSON,
YOU WOULD SEE CONCRETE UTILITY
POLES SNAPPED IN HALF.
THERE WAS A LOT OF DEBRIS.
SO THAT WILL TAKE A LOT OF
EFFORT.
BUT WE ARE BARGING PEOPLE THERE.
AND WHEN THE CAUSEWAY IS BACK
OPEN, YOU WILL BE ABLE TO RUN
TRUCKS AGAIN.
>> GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, THANKS
FOR YOUR TIME AND EFFORT